how do you keep an audience guessing
with plot twists and reveals so I when I
was working on the honeymoon phase
I had this mindset of the film it's like
a Hot Wheel car track where maybe it's
because I grew up with Hot Wheel cars
but on the tracks for the hot wheel cars
there's like these little spinning
motors that will push the car further so
it's like okay goes down the hill it
reaches the bottom and it reaches a part
where you know naturally the gravity
would stop the car because it would run
to the end of the track and then there
would be a motor that would push it
along further and throughout the track
there would be all these motors that
eventually would you know push the car
to where it needed to go next and to be
that's kind of like a good analogy for a
script where you have these key scenes
in the story which are you're like
motors that push the story further so
like the attention grabbing moments
because a lot of points are your story
or kind of business for you you know
your characters are doing things that
you know on a surface level maybe aren't
the most entertaining things to watch
but are important to the story but you
need these motors to you know keep the
audience guessing and keep them engaged
so in honeymoon phase we would you know
throughout the story when I was
outlining I would pick points where I'm
like I think we need a motor here and
then you come up with a twist or
something that made sense within the
realm of the film to keep the audience
guessing and you you know do that by
thinking about the characters and where
they are at that point in the story and
you know what their belief is I guess in
their present world and then how do you
flip that on its head by making them
question their own reality and this is a
psychological thriller so I guess that's
why some of that terminology is coming
into play there but yeah the hot wheel
track thing is kind of how I view a
story and so then the the loop the the
that would be toward the end yeah yeah
and I think that's probably a very
Hollywood way of thinking about it where
a lot of blockbuster films have their
set-piece moments they would be the
motors you know or the big reveals and
then you know in between you have the
scenes that are important to the story
but maybe aren't your trailer moments or
the things that are going to leave you
like with your draw
dropped because you know you find out
that this person was cheating on this
person or you know that person's the
killer you know the the gear moments
yeah are there any stories you love that
are more from the arthouse genre that
aren't Hollywood that you there was a
really powerful the way the characters
played against one another trying to
think most of most of the films that I
grew up with were Hollywood films and
independent films like I've as I you
know matured as a film goer I start
appreciating more independent film as
well but arthouse film was nothing that
I was able to ever
I guess connect with as a viewer and
that's not to say that I don't respect
it as an art form because I think it's
it's beautiful and there's so much to be
said in art house movies it's just as a
viewer I could never connect with it so
it's more of a genre that I respect but
maybe don't necessarily connect with
you